ja ich finde wir haben hier in der
Hauptstadt durchaus ein Problem wenn der
erste Mai zum ersten Januar wird wenn
wir erleben dass es keinerlei Respekt
mehr für Einsatz und Sicherheitskräfte
und unserer Stadt gibt und wenn man zu
der Schlussfolgerung kommen muss dass
gerade in der Hauptstadt Deutschlands
durch eine Linkskoalition das still
toleriert wird wenn wir über einen die
Beweislastumkehr bei der Berliner
Polizei sprechen statt uns hinter die
Beamten im Einsatz zu stellen die jeden
Tag unseren rechtsstaatsverteidigen dann
müssen wir hinschauen wenn wir sehen
dass es eine
eine politisch handelnde Partei in
dieser Stadt gibt mit Justiz Senatoren
und Stadträten die klangkriminalität
nicht begegnen sondern sich hier noch
schützend davor stellen was meine ich
damit wenn eine bezirksstadträtin in
Neukölln am Ende ein verbundeinsatz der
Polizei unterbindet und verhindert wo
man gemeinsam mit den Ordnungskräften
hätte vorgehen können dann haben wir ein
Problem in unserem Land und ich glaube
dass wir hier in der Stadt Berlin
deshalb eine stärk unsere Justiz
brauchen die besser ausgestattet ist mit
mehr Richterinnen und Richtern mit einer
besseren Digitalisierung einer engeren
Zusammenarbeit mit der Innenbehörde um
brennpunktstaatsanwaltschaften zu
schaffen und wir gerade in den Regionen
wo wir diese Ereignisse erlebt haben
über ein neues aufstiegsversprechen
reden das heißt deutlich machen dass wir
uns um Bildungs- und Jugendarbeit
kümmern
das bedeutet wenn ihre Partei reinkommt
hier in der Hauptstädten wird es mehr
Richter geben mehr Polizisten geben mehr
Ausstattung geben das haben wir immer in
jeder Haushaltsberatung in den letzten
sechs Jahren hier in Berlin beantragt
und es wurde immer abgelehnt das wurde
immer abgelehnt gerade von Grünen und
Linken die gesagt haben wir haben keinen
mehr Bedarf in dieser Stadt bei
Richterinnen und Richtern wir müssen die
Justiz nicht besser ausstatten wir
müssen nicht die Justiz besser
digitalisieren ja das würden wir weil
wir haben eine wachsende Stadt die auch
wachsende Anforderungen hat und in
keiner Stadt in Deutschland erleben wir
mehr Auseinandersetzung als hier wieso
haben wir hier mehr kriminelle Kleber
auf den Straßen als in anderen
Bundesländern
aus meiner Sicht weil man diese Dinge
hier still toleriert und weiß dass es
hier ein politisches Klima gibt wo man
immer ans Äußerste gehen kann und
deshalb sage ich wir haben in dieser
Stadt kein Problem an Gesetzen sondern
wir haben ein Vollzugsdefizit und diese
Selbstverständlichkeiten die möchte ich
in Berlin wieder herstellen damit wir in
dieser Stadt endlich das nicht mehr
erleben und klarere Regeln auch
durchsetzen und die Beamten in dieser
Stadt auch Stärken im Einsatz im Dienst
den sie für uns alle jeden Tag
vollziehen und dieser Stadt denn hinter
jeder Uniform steckt eben auch eine
Mutter oder ein Vater der hier in dieser
Stadt Verantwortung übernimmt für uns
alle ist die erste Verteidigungslinie
unseres recht Staates und die würde ich
gerne wieder stärken und das ist eine
alte Forderung also ich erinnere mich
Katrin der Heisingen hat das vor über
zehn Jahren schon gefordert dass die
Justiz besser aufgestellt wird damals
auch unter dem Aspekte wie kriegt man
Jugendkriminalität aus migrantischen
Milieus in den Griff auch natürlich im
Sinne der Jugendlichen nicht nur im
Sinne der Gesellschaft sondern weil die
sind auch verloren wenn sie irgendwann
eine eine dauerkriminelle Karriere haben
und aus ihnen nichts mehr gescheites
wird also wie man die Probleme wirklich
angeht das haben wir schon
verschiedentlich auch kluge Leute gesagt
das ist nur nie passiert worden und da
haben sie völlig recht das sind Vollzugs
Problem weil es eben auch in der in der
Politik diejenigen gibt die sagen alles
ist gut in Berlin wir müssen gar nichts
machen ja auch in den Schulen auch da
haben wir natürlich wir haben Brennpunkt
Schulen da brennt die Hütte sozusagen
und ich habe das selber erlebt in einem
Fall in der Köln wo auch eine
Beratungsstelle sich der der Themen
annehmen wollte da hieß es sofort
Rassismus Generalverdacht dann machen
wir gar nichts ja so dabei gibt es ja
viele Schulen mittlerweile die
tatsächlich Sicherheitsdienste
beschäftigt haben ja was so zu unserer
Schulzeit noch völlig und denkbar war
das ist sehr häufig so also ich habe da
auch gerade für die FDP Mann Vortrag
gehalten mit Lehrern und über
schulkriminalität geht das ist auch ein
riesen Thema das sind amerikanische
verhält aber ich finde wir haben ja
jetzt eine ich finde es gut dass wir
diese Diskussion heute hier führen weil
meine Sorge ist dass Silvester und der
erste januar immer blasser wird und wir
uns wieder dieser Diskussionen unserer
Stadt nicht stellen die wesentlich
umfänglicher ist wo wir auch an die
Ursachen ran müssen wo wir auch deutlich
machen müssen das Postleitzahl und
Herkunft nicht über die Chancen eines
Kindes entscheiden dürfen sondern das
Bildungssystem stark sein muss deswegen
aufstiegsversprechen erneuern und dass
wir ein funktionierenden Rechtsstaat
haben und da sind wir hier in dieser
Stadt einfach auch schlecht aufgestellt
und wenn ich sehe dass
das eben jetzt von der Tagesordnung
einfach wegkommt dann werden wir diese
Ereignisse leider wieder in der Stadt
erleben und das möchte
Berlin von Bayern was lernen
auch das ist die alte Platte Türe also
von Bayern lernen heißt dies und jenes
alles mögliche anführen ich glaube die
Bayern und die Berliner sind immer gut
miteinander ausgekommen zwar immer
früher hat man gesagt Hassliebe
Verhältnisse also ich ist ein besonderes
Verhältnis und ich bin immer stolz
darauf ganz ganz viele Berliner im
Urlaub in meinem Wahlkreis zu haben
zwischen Chiemsee und Königsee und das
Wasser Werbeteil
ich war ein großer Verfechter im Jahr
1991 in Bonn zu verbleiben das war einer
meiner wenigen politischen Fehler muss
ich sagen ich bin froh dass das alles
nach Berlin gegangen ist und ich fühle
mich hier wohl unter der Voraussetzung
dass ich immer naja wenn man in der
Berliner in der politischen Blase ist
ist es etwas anders als die Bilder die
jetzt auch eingeblendet waren in
Neukölln und so weit ist das sind zwei
Welten eigentlich mit dem unser eins
kommt mit dem wenigen Verbindung ich bin
Silvester Neujahr einfach nicht in
Berlin und da bin ich im Rügen Bayern
ist schöner Aussage wissen sie dass das
würde ich mir von viel mehr Politikern
noch wünschen na dass sie gesagt haben
dass sie da weniger Berührungspunkte
haben weil genauso ist es auch anders
ich dachte hier wird von einem anderen
Berlin berichtet aber das ist natürlich
das wahre Berlin und unser Rechtsstaat
steht doch unter Dauerfeuer an diesen
Stellen schauen Sie doch total Feuer ja
was was hier am ersten Mai am ersten
Januar passiert ist schauen Sie nach
lützerath wir können ja uns mit all
diesen Fragen auseinandersetzen und
deshalb finde ich es wichtig dass man in
diesen Zeiten eben auch deutlich sagt
wenn der Rechtsstaat so unter Dauerfeuer
steht da müssen wir auch dafür sorgen
dass der Rechtsstaat besser funktioniert
oder hier in Berlin die
Selbstverständlichkeiten funktionieren
und ich finde es dann hoch irritierend
wenn die Grünen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
darüber nachdenken das Thema Clan
Kriminalität aus dem polizeilichen
Lagebild zu streichen weil sie der
Auffassung sind dass das da ähm
hineingehört
so dann greifen dann müssen wir das
müssen wir Klartext über diese Frage
sprechen und und uns besser aufstellen